so first of all boris johnson's speech
today was i think it's fair to say light
on policy detail it was also pretty
light on references to climate change
now compare that to a speech to the u.n
general assembly a couple of weeks ago
which he dedicated entirely to the need
for action on climate change and as the
host of the huge cop 26 climate summit
in glasgow coming up in only a few weeks
what does this say about his leadership
and how should leaders approach climate
action
so mariam to you first of all so there
was little reference to it in his
conference speech but we did hear from
the prime minister this week making a
new pledge to turn the power grid green
by 2035.
the latest some would say in a line of
quite ambitious climate targets so is
that what good climate leadership looks
like
i do think that the time for pledges and
commitments is kind of coming to an end
i think people will need action they
need to know how we're going to get
there and how what it's going to mean
for every single person that lives in
this country and i think
pledges are a great place to start but
it seems that if we end there we're
never going to be able to take the steps
we need to take to to address this
climate crisis
would you agree with that jerome that um
targets are all very well but you have
to spell out to the public to businesses
perhaps the fellow politicians that you
need to get on side as well
what it means to reach those targets and
do you think that
joe as an advisor to joe biden do you
think he's doing any better on that
front
absolutely i think that when we talk
about the differences between the uk and
the us right now the u.s has a whole a
government approach and we talk about it
from an electric vehicle standpoint from
a job standpoint and from an overall
solution standpoint and we have the
details and i think that's what is was
really encouraging about the us is that
we are working towards that and we are
seeing tangible results but but but joe
biden has a fight on his hand to
convince everybody in government hasn't
he to to come on side with some of the
plans it's not all straightforward there
yeah absolutely right now we're seeing a
3.5 trillion dollar infrastructure bill
which if passed would accomplish many of
this administration's goals and that's
really a challenge right now over the
next um week or so we're working to
convince other elected officials that
this is an urgent priority and has to be
tackled um with the details at the
forefront well yes and finance is really
important isn't it mary i'm not just in
convincing fellow politicians there are
different departments within government
that are all vying for money in a
post-covered era but also you've got to
convince the public as well who might
worry that it's going to cost them more
these plans to go green it that's that
takes leadership doesn't it
absolutely and it's also about really
showing
all of us here in in the uk that
actually by
reaching our agreeing to targets by
making
those this you know those pledges and
and actually attaining them that we're
actually going to be able to live up to
some of the um
targets that people want in their own
lives when it comes to jobs and health
like the the environmental targets we
set also let us
achieve other things that people do
already care about so it's not just
about diverting everything to the
environment but looking at how all these
things intersect well yeah it's really
interesting you mentioned jobs actually
because uh jeremy i'm just going to
point out what joe biden has said about
jobs and the green economy he said it's
going to create millions of jobs i think
it's a gigantic opportunity to create
really good jobs and clearly joe biden's
strategy is trying to frame this as a
kind of positive economic step but is
that cutting through people are worried
there aren't they about jobs in fossil
fuel industries going and and the
country's really quite divided on the
climate question isn't it
i think that it actually is very
straightforward when we talk about jobs
it's when we talk about workforce
development we transition people who are
working in fossil fuels to now install
solar panels in wind turbines it's a
jobs perspective at the very forefront
every solution will create millions of
good paying jobs and the biggest thing
we're working on right now is called the
civilian climate court which would
mobilize millions of young americans to
be able to work directly in the the
solutions that will save us when we talk
about the cost of solutions we have to
talk about also the cost of not
implementing them the cost of natural
disasters devastating communities is far
higher than the solutions that are
needed that also will have a positive
job impact as well
okay and interesting to see if that does
bring people on side